in this video I'll show you how to
superimpose structures this is great for
when you're trying to compare maybe an
unbound enzyme with an enzyme that's
bound to an inhibitor you can look for
structural changes and things like that
also if a protein undergoes a large
conformational change you'll be able to
do measurements and compare how much
things move but first I want to tell you
a little bit about NMR structures so
let's fetch one right now NMR structures
are really cool this is the NMR
structure of ubiquitin which is a
regulatory protein involved in many
processes and in eukaryotes and so
ubiquitin can become a covalently
attached conjugated to things to other
proteins and cause them to undergo
conformational changes cause them to be
tagged for proteases to break them down
and many other things so here is
ubiquitin but this structure is special
because notice right down here we have a
hundred and sixteen states and this
means this NMR structure shows many
different confirmations of the protein
so we can either press play here we can
scroll manually through the
confirmations so notice that change so
we could do this one at a time or we can
press play and get this rapidly moving
protein it'll be rapidly moving through
all the states and you'll be able to see
those changes we can all do also do this
from the command line by typing em play
and so now you can move this in 3d space
and kind of experience the flexibility
of this protein here but this is really
fast so we can actually go up to the
movie and reset the frame rate to be
something a little bit slower and so
let's just go with five frames per
second and now we can really see the
flexibility and you can really see
this alpha helix is shifting and so
ubiquitin binds many many many proteins
in the body and it is known to be in
many different confirmations when it
binds and so now we can see some of the
flexibility that allows it to so
promiscuously bind other proteins to
stop the movie we can type em stop or we
can press the stop button down here now
that structure of ubiquitin was not from
Homo sapiens so I just opened up a new
PI mole window and we're gonna go ahead
and fetch the structure of ubiquitin
that is from Homo sapiens
so we'll fetch one D 3 z and there we
have it this one only has ten states
that's why I wanted to start with the
other one because we have less
confirmations here for the Homo sapiens
one and of course we can press play and
see it wiggle around really experience
the dynamics of the protein which i
think is just so cool alright but this
video is about superimposing so let's
fetch some things that we can
superimpose now so I'll use the up
arrows to get my fetch command back and
I'm going to fetch one J seven four and
that'll pop up in the frame and I also
want to fetch to GM I alright so we have
a few proteins in here and now we want
to superimpose them so this is actually
an enzyme that is involved in the
process of conjugating covalently
attaching ubiquitin to other proteins
it's involved in the second stage of
that and so I want to just compare the
structures see if there's any major
changes and so I'm gonna use a command
there are two commands to do this the
align command and the super command the
PI mul wiki says that the super command
is more robust so that's what I'll use
and I'm gonna superimpose everything on
to to GM I so the last protein that I
brought in because that's the protein
that's bound to ubiquitin and so what I
need to do is type these codes to
superimpose them onto this but the
second PDB ID that I type is where the
first protein is going to go so it's
wise to put this one last both time so
let me just show you what I mean here 1
D 3 Z comma and I'm going to have this
snap on to 2 GM I and so you can see it
jumped right over here pretty well
aligned and now we want to superimpose
the other one so I'm gonna use my up
arrow keys leave the two GM I here and
we'll go 1 j 7 4 and that'll superimpose
this onto here and now let's display our
sequence we have another piece that's
not part of the superimposition and that
might you know get a little confusing as
we're looking at things maybe we want to
hide this chain and so I'm gonna go
ahead and select and oh it looks very
very convenient that this was a chain a
right here so I'm just gonna press shift
to select this whole chain I can rename
it we'll call it on aligned and then I
can operate on this separately and just
hide it and so we can see we have
everything lined up here if I went to
I'm just gonna go ahead and zoom on the
ubiquitin bound portion and so now we
can actually go through our states here
or we could we could play the movie and
just kind of watch this wiggle around or
we can manually if we click the right
thing go through the states and kind of
see which one of these aligns best with
what we have here
and so state five actually looks pretty
good and we really want to look for the
parts where we have are actually well
maybe that that is a little bit and
that's a little bit different here see
we have more order in this green one
than this pink one right here the loops
don't matter as much those are very
flexible but these secondary structural
elements that primal shows you know as
the alpha helix and the beta sheet those
are fairly well defined and that's why
they show up in this way and so lining
up those pieces is more important the
loops are very flexible and so who knows
where they will be in the NMR structure
at that given time the last thing I want
to show you is how to superimpose when
the super command doesn't work well for
you so I'll go ahead and fetch that same
ubiquitin structure
and I'm going to fetch
new protein one nb8 and one NBS
this is addy you Bickerton aiding enzyme
and so it removes ubiquitin from other
proteins and so here we have it let's go
ahead and we want to align on to this
one NBF the last thing that i brought in
and so we'll use the super command and
that popped in right there we can zoom
in and see that ubiquitin is aligned
fairly well and now let's go ahead and
try to superimpose the protein that's
unbound to the one that is bound to
ubiquitin so we'll just replace that
first part with one nb8 and this jumps
over here and we can see that this
really is an aligning well we have an
alpha helix there's nothing there these
beta sheets are kind of intertwined so
it's a really good thing to check our
sequence at this point and make sure of
course you want the sequence to be the
same from the same organism and we can
see that this sequence here is aligned
is matched up pretty well let's say so
when this sort of thing happens you know
it might just be the conformational
change is so great that pi mole doesn't
know what to do perhaps it's choosing a
different part of the protein notice
this one is much bigger on the the pink
one here one and bf so it has a lot more
going on in the structure so maybe it
doesn't know where to align it very well
so what we can do is create a selection
so I'm gonna take this chain a and I'm
gonna scroll over and then I see this
part where some residues are missing the
crystallographer knows they're there but
they couldn't actually see them so I'm
just gonna go up to that point so I'll
press shift and click so I can select
that whole part and now I'm going to
rename my selection so we'll call this
one n b8 SEL e
and that'll pop up here now I'm going to
click elsewhere start at the beginning
here again and just go up to the same
point and make a selection
now we'll rename the selection to one
and be f SE le and there we have it now
we're going to reapply our super command
but using the selections that we made so
all I have to add on here is se le se le
and look at that that's a lot better now
we have a lot of parts of this protein
that aren't aligning and so let's go
ahead and we know that we aligned chain
a so let's just check I think it's going
to be yeah this is all belonging to
chain B and so we can we can even select
the waters if we want select all of this
and I'm not even going to make a
selection from it I'm just gonna hide
everything for this quick analysis and
then we have these other pieces if you
don't know where to find them you can
click on your structure and get one of
these residues within this selected then
scroll over so we see that we're in this
chain here so I can just go ahead and
select this whole chain hide everything
and then we have a chain or two over
here let's go ahead and click on that so
we can find it so you see that's this
little line that's lighting up that I
can scroll over to and find which chain
this is and so if the residue is right
there and it's lit up I'm just gonna
scroll a little bit more to select this
whole chain
all right and now we have that I'm going
to go ahead and hi
the waters hide non-bonded clean this up
a little because we just want to focus
on this structure here so when I read
the paper about this enzyme it told me
that the active site residues are
histidine 464 and cysteine 223 so I'm
going to go ahead and find those
residues and make a selection in chain a
of each of these so going back to chain
a soulless a right here so we want four
six two two three first so here's our
two two three so I'm just going to do
this for one protein at a time then I'll
scroll over find four six so here's 4-6
6-4 6-4 is two before that and so there
are my residues lit up and I'll rename
this to active one nb8 and let's click
away and do the same for the 1nvf
protein
all right now I'm gonna go ahead and
let's just zoom in on these residues and
I haven't shown them as anything so for
each of these let's show Stix and I'll
do that here as well and now we can see
a major shift in these active site
residues upon binding ubiquitin and we
can actually um just display these one
at a time if we want to just turn off
one protein and examine these residues
but I'm gonna turn them both on for a
second it's sometimes useful to measure
how much a an individual residue has
shifted sometimes it's interesting to
look at the distance between the
catalytic residues so in in this protein
we can already see these are really far
away these are much closer so they're
brought much closer once this is bound
to ubiquitin so we might just open our
measurement wizard and I think we could
just maybe measure these nitrogen's to
get a sense of how much this has shifted
so we'll go from this nitrogen to this
nitrogen and we can see this residue has
had a 2.8 angstrom shift from this
analysis so in this lesson we learned a
little bit about NMR structures and how
they show us a little bit more of the
dynamics of how a protein actually
Wiggles around in our body we learned
how to superimpose structures so we
could compare them and we learned what
to do when the super impose command
doesn't really work that well how we can
make selections and align those and one
thing I really want to say here is that
a crystal structure versus an NMR
structure the crystal structure is like
taking a picture of somebody running
past you you get a snapshot of them at
this one moment but they were
dynamically running and moving and all
you see is that one piece so when you
see a crystal structure it's limited
because these proteins are wiggling and
moving around within our bodies and we
only see one piece of that so even these
are just one moment
in time so it's important to think that
and I think that the NMR structures
really help us appreciate how the
crystal structure
you know just gives us that snapshot but
the NMR structure shows us the dynamics
thanks so much for watching